au pays d'accueil de sud sauvage dans
les hauts de saint joseph
marie-andrée cultive comme beaucoup
d'autres de ses collègues l'authenticité
de la réunion table d'hôte ou auberge de
campagne comme seul de notre invité
c'est l'amour du terroir la simplicité
et la chaleur de l'accueil que nous vous
proposons de partager lieu de départ
typique pour nos balades et découvertes
pourquoi que je suis à visiter dans quoi
bon on n'est pas loin de la maison du
document qui a peint degré on a des
sentiers de randonnée il n'est pas loin
aussi du volcan palois c'est à cammas et
l'om enfin c est là qu c est pas
tellement divisée en une heure et demie
on nous vole quand on a le jardin des
épices ont fait partie aussi la route
des parfums des épices donc il ya pas
mal de choses à voir sur cette route il
ya le fond ford déshabille à la paillote
a pas faim qui fait les distilleries de
vétiver géraniums plus haut il ya des
sentiers de randonnée et en santé qu'est
ce donc il ya de quoi quand même à
rester 2 jouant sur la zone et votre
belle chine csbc quand le béa jezzy
existe depuis 96
on a reconstruit tout neuf mais depuis
87 on a cette activité table d'hôte et
jean beaudottes
qu'est ce qui différencie de la table
date à l'auberge la table d'hôtes c'est
une petite quantité ont tous recevoir
jusqu'à 25 personnes et l'auberge volé
entre 60 et 80 personnes selon la croix
de la salle on a droit aussi à voir si
chambres six chambres d'hôtes
est-ce que vous avez une spécialité en
ce qui concerne la classe b de
spécialités bon travail avec les fruits
les légumes de saison donc c'est pour ça
qu'on dit n'a pas vraiment spécialité
mais on a beaucoup
donc on allait les goûts longtemps qui
dit la songe crise là son jus mers du
sud
le pape un camp c'est la saison les
goyaviers quand c'est la saison patate
chouchou en saison et puis bon niveau et
vachon n'a poulets canards cochon donc
là les songes elle est récoltée dauphin
on laisse avec la terre pour pouvoir
conserver
on va consommer plus les petits on
replante savons appellation juillet du
sud
ces titres avaient été enlevés de
latéral
et pour les gâteaux il faut qu'on cuit
quand même un peu comme la patate douce
et après on prépare un gâteau le gâteau
pour les bavarois que les beignets aussi
sauf dans l'avion dans le micro y couper
en petits carrés au micro mais si la bio
n'est un peu dur
il faut mettre un peu laissé la viande
un peu plus rarement c'est une spéciale
à faire c'est une variété rare
withera parce qu'on n'est pas comment on
avait commencé à planter ses avait pas
beaucoup et avec le temps on a fini par
faire à ce moment là on peut arriver
quand même des 103 100 kg on l'a
suffisamment pour quand les gens nous
demandent et avec la chinoise pour
augmenter la plaine du gange à l'abandon
voilà d'accord qu'est ce qui fait la
cuisine ici la cuisine c'est plus mon
mari la cuisine au feu de bois donc
c'est des grandes marmites c'est lui qui
fait sinon tout le monde y met la main à
la pâte
enfin moi j'ai fait des formations de
cuisine entre plusieurs transformations
donc les enfants aussi a fait de vous
étiez dans l'interview on avait cuisiné
pâtissier serveuses sont comblés et vous
est-ce que vous rencontré beaucoup de
difficultés à tenir le belge
actuellement
ben tout seul oui parce qu'on participe
eu vraiment des activités comme les
allemands par exemple la demande sur le
hâle de manifestations un peu plus le
salon régal non peu plus donc il ya de
fait parce que je suis tout seul n'est
pas demandeur donc on peut pas après
abandonnés ici pour aller voir ailleurs
je viens vous avez quand même continuer
si assez sûrement pas composé d'enfants
les études après les études bas ils
prendront
le relais à nous on va arrêter on va pas
fait tous notre vie a fait de la
restauration
il croit que c'est pas c'est pas pensé
ah oui dans la restauration qu'on avait
20 ans c'est bon c'est quoi que les
banques a commencé à voter dimanche
si on arrive à la retraite en bonne
santé et est capable de la restauration
c'est un travail très dur c'est qu'on a
pas que la restauration a fait on a tué
les animaux préparés légumes pain c'est
tout un il faut être dedans on prend
notre travail c'est pareil c'est pas
facile c'est pas combien exactement
les restaurants on parle de la volaille
des tanneurs et m'avait dit ici que vous
faites de la transformation des aliments
est ce qu'il ya deux ans une
transformation évidemment oui donc on a
pris les vaches de gavage et la
transformation
donc on a fait commettre aux 4 ou 9 ans
de transformations mais maintenant on
n'a plus tellement fait de problèmes
d'atelier il fallait trois bassins c'est
loin donc soit et ainsi abandonner si
vous allez travailler votre
transformation pour nous c'était plutôt
rentable donc ce qu'on fait on fait un
petit peu ici pour la polo beige contre
c'est que nous les vraiment embêté c'est
les chèvres à williams en a ça c'est là
la folie
leur taille bruit tout homme digne à
gauche et pas de chien de ce qui
concerne la transformation des légumes
et des fruits vous le faites ici voilà
c'est tout voilà c'est pour le bien de
ses collaborateurs uniquement pour
consommer je me suis d'accord vous me
citer un petit peu ce que vous faites en
transformation de l'information et la
chance oui à chaque enchère de panique
sachant qu'un pain et qu'on les
confitures de toutes les fruits sont là
on vient on fait confiance de nos ténors
l'est où les pâtés et rillettes le foie
gras pour les fêtes on gomme que les
balles donc les mâles et donc la variété
c'est le barbare edreams barbarie et
erbate un qu'on appelle et de cette
couleur un peu gris plus pâle donc on
les gave entre quatre mois quatre mois
et demi
ils ont déjà 4 kg 5 aussi donc et en gav
et enfin après que trois semaines de
gavage il peut arriver entre 5 à 6 kg et
le x 350 à 400 grammes donc on peut
avoir des fois de plus de 400 grammes à
500 g donc c'est pas les bons choix pour
le transformer pour pas fondre c'est 350
à 400 grammes
mais comment vous estimez ça parce qu'on
la barre au poids de cana weaver là je
suis seul à jouer mais fouet
un aliment bien suivi le canon parcours
qui peut manger des herbes pour pour
bien faire les gésiers les jabots sinon
l'alimentation est différent maïs maïs
va utiliser way et au gabon maïs aussi
oui et que ce qui fait de gavage c'est
toujours mon mari c'est assez compliqué
ben c'est pas tellement compliqué mais
il faut connaître faut peut être tous
les matins à la même heure tous les
soirs la même heure et puis pas être
bousculé parce que le gars veulent ce
qui est très important c'est comme trait
les vaches il faut le a est respectée
sur le bruit sans la pièce on est
stressé pour avoir de l'entraînement
parce que si on va battre sur le canon
et il va pas on va pas cette fois est-ce
que vous avez été formé pour justement
tenir 7,7 bh oui enfin tout dépend
j'ai fait une petite formation femmes en
milieu rural donc après tout a suivi au
petit élevage poulets canards lapins
tout ce qui sur le lait aussi j'ai fait
une formation pour le fromage et une
formation de gestion tout ce qui touche
d'activité avec cole et tout ça j'ai
fait et donc la transformation que j'ai
fais pas qui était plus loin c'était
deux ans et c'est pour ça ça me permet
aujourd'hui de former les autres femmes
qui voudraient apprendre à faire de la
cuisine
et puis de la transformation et comment
ça se passe les stages c'est ce qu'elles
viennent tous les jours sur un acte de
temps ou plus de falla mais comment ça
se passe bell a laissé lui tous deux
séries comme ils viennent
ils ont transmis trois semaines quatre
semaines et donc c'est soit en version
canine et comme cette mère de famille
ils ont des enfants aussi donc si vous
travaillez le dimanche travail le
dimanche je vais récupérer mercredi et
on s'arrange avec le connaissant il ya
peu de sagesse
oui bon on peut pas faire plus
l'investissement financier que quand
même attendre avant le départ si enfin
on n'a pas pris tout départ pour la fia
au fur et à mesure et moi c'est j'aime
bien j'aime pas ma est habillé j'aime
être simple mais j'aime bien voir du bon
matériel de cuisine d'accord mon plaisir
c'est ça c'est c'est investir dans du
matériel cuisine j'aime biette est
équipé est ce que c'est un luxe c'est
une nécessité aujourd'hui au niveau prix
c'est le luxe est pour moi je les
nécessités sas arrosoirs donc on peut
faire la cuisine diététique se fait des
confitures diététique
donc on
on peut pas ses fruits on met le
supplante a suffi de régime
au programme on met ces cocos on a sa
confiture au milieu juste pas de la
farine en a pas de route on dirait donc
un peu de farine ou est-ce que vous
estimez vous êtes assez connu est ce que
vous trouvez qu'il n'ya pas encore une
fois on dit qu'on est assez connue mais
a des fois on rencontre des gens qui
connaît pas aussi alors à plus il faut
toujours le chien il faut toujours
renouvelés il faut toujours avec les
jeunes et comment vous faites pour est
ce que vous êtes comme il de bouche à
oreille comme ça aurait il pu on fait
partie de l'association qui s'appelle
pays d'accueil oui donc on fait des
bides les gîtes de france fait aussi
liquide
donc les gens de penser à des médias
est-ce que vous pensez que les femmes
ont oublié un petit peu le rôle dans la
piscine parce que l'on mange moins bien
ils on t pas oublié parce que comme il
voit là les stagiaires qui arrive au psg
ils ont envie de faire quelque chose il
faut quand même avoir plus formation
plus d'informations pour former les
femmes qui ont envie vraiment quelque
chose
moi j'ai bien envie de montrer à des
fois c'est là qu'on voit qu'il ya des
fruits qui gagne même chez saison pleine
crise ont ils savent pas ils ont pas d
idées et donc si peu et qu'ils ont un
outil pour mature
m